ciao ragazzi benvenuti all'angolo di
willwoosh per quando avete un attacco
d'arte allora è arrivato il momento di
fare un regalo a vostra madre a una
vostra amica e non avete i soldi per
comprarne magari una borsetta di gucci
non fa niente tutto quello che vi serve
stare a casa vostra
vediamo un po come fare una cosa
prendiamo il foglio giochi pieno a metà
e con l'aiuto di un pochino di colla che
potete benissimo trovare nei trucchi
vostra madre
tendiamo lieve strato sopra attacchiamo
una base del fiore nel cuore poi
inseriremo i vari fiori per creare un
fiore è semplice basta semplicemente
fare ecco qui un fiore colorarlo chiama
così e poi stropicciano torino per dare
un pochino l'idea di mosso inserire il
fiore nel vaso a questo punto aiutatevi
magari con delle foglie che create con
del semplice stop grave una una passata
un cucchiaino con l'air bene di farina
che te rasoi quanto ne pare voterà per
aggiornarlo un pochino semplice pasta di
pomodoro per dare dei toni di rosso in
maniera molto gentile con uno di questi
detergenti per per cucina
dategli delle spruzzatine a questo punto
lasciate un pochino riposare per due
giorni dopo due giorni dovreste avere
qualcosa così insomma è è bello enel
semplice come avete visto da lei dalle
indicazioni al prossimo attacco d'arte
mesi ciao a tutti sono sicuro che molti
vi siete sentiti dire li misure non
conta l'importante è che lo si sa chiusa
ed è bene tv è tutto ok
una cosa simpatica qual è che quando
tutti i giri tipo ti allontani ma
nemmeno passano tre secondi che subì
parte il quindi come sta messo a taiz
ma tipo no no no allora no di più di più
ma che così vabbè che tipo di scuro di
sì naturalmente questo qui se a al
poveretto è va bene perché in caso
contrario in caso di in caso di martin
allora diciamo che si va anche peggio si
fa ancora più depressi come come cosa
tipo no tipo tipo ecco oggi mi dispiace
cerco di dire due importanti fosse la
prima ringraziare clio diciamo di uno si
aspetta che sia un po ciao ragazzi so
che io make up essa una gran [ __ ] perché
faccio il tutorial su internet mi sono
e competere cioè ha fatto una cosa che
sinceramente vedete io sto riprovando
arrivato il video non ci riesca ad
esprimere le cose a dirle mettiamola
così cioè una cosa che non mi aspettavo
perché è molto incondizionata non è che
ti faccio un favore tu mi fai un altro
perché non vedo non vedo in che modo una
cosa molto gentile una cosa ti ha
colpito e a parte questo la somma non
sai che voglio ringraziare tutti gli
iscritti tutti gli iscritti perché io
leggo ogni vostro commento e ci metto lì
la tappa da tagli largo e alcuni sono
veramente geniali geniali infatti dal
prossimo video per nella mente quelli
che preferisco è assolutamente metto
quelli che preferisco del video commesso
prima e cioè alcuni sono geniali in
geniali note mesi cioè ma poi vi rendete
conto che a casa io questo cioè questa
kitsch ata cioè mia madre ha comprato
questa roba che quando uno entra
la prima cosa capire questo bello